ما الجديد لديك لا زالت هذه الاليات
الثقيله تعمل تحاول ايضا ان تعبد طريق
النجاه
للاشخاص الموجودين تحت هذه
الانقاض وكذلك لفرق البحث والانقاذ
نعم نعم بالضبط هذه الجرافه الكبيره تحاول
ازاله الكتل الخرسانيه مع هذه الجرافه
هناك شخص تقني وخبير من فريق من الفريق
الانقاذ الذي قام بانتشال الاشخاص الذين
كانوا على قيد الحياه من قبل هو الذي يشرف
على عمل هذه الجرافه مع
مع الفريق التركي كما نشاهد هناك اشخاص من
الفريق الانقاذ
من قربستان وايضا سائق الجرافه التركي
يعمل وفق ما
التعليمات التي تاتيه منهم في محاوله
لتجريف بعض الكتل الخرسانيه ليعود فريق
ليستكمل العمل في هذا الموقع
ساحاول مع الاسف
نايف الشرطه منعتنا بشكل كامل من الدخول
الى الموقع سنحاول قدر الامكان ان نرصد
الصوره او نتابع ما يجري نعم الان احد
عناصر فريق الانقاذ يتوجه الصوره واضحه
لنا زيدان يعني في هذه الاثناء يعني نحن
نتابعها بشكل قريب حتى ايضا لفرق البحث
الان وربما هذه الجرافه احد عناصر فرق فرق
فرق البحث يتقدم الى الموقع الذي تم
انتشال الاشخاص العالقين سيتاكد من وجود
في حال لم يكن هناك عوائق او كتل خرسانيه
ضخمه تمنع استئناف العمل
سيعود الفريق ربما بعد قليل وفي حال كان
هناك كتل خرسانيه ايضا سيتم ازالتها بهذه
الجرافه
الضخمه
الان فريق الانقاذ يتفحص هذا الموقع يفحص
هذا الموقع
هذا
الخبير يفحظ يفحص الموقع يريد تاكد في حال
كان هناك اشخاص اخرين ما زالوا عالقين تحت
الانقاض ام لا